[Música]
entrevista de prensa en directo américa
de france 24 rosa pérez + euia estaba
conmigo en el estudio rosa bienvenida a
buena mañana de lunes vamos a abrir esta
revista de prensa el día de hoy lunes 8
de agosto con las reacciones a la
posesión del nuevo presidente de
colombia gustavo petro empezamos por la
prensa internacional
buenos días raúl exactamente y la
noticia la encontramos en muchísimos
medios de comunicación sin embargo no
son tantos los que destacan esta toma de
posesión en la portada en papel como si
sucedió luego de las elecciones no pero
vamos a ver por ejemplo el medio francés
liberación que titula petro y márquez
investidos en colombia américa latina se
afianza a la izquierda colombia se unió
domingo a los otros países países del
continente que han pasado a la izquierda
un club que sin embargo está atravesado
por corrientes radicalmente opuestas sin
embargo vemos en la tercera de chile en
este periódico también en su portada en
papel la foto del momento en que gustavo
petro saludó a gabriel boric que sí que
pudimos ver que fue una saludo con una
alegría genuina que demuestra pues eso
la complicidad entre dos aliados
regionales ya recordemos que boris por
ejemplo propuso a francia a márquez
cuando estuvo de viaje en el chile
precisamente que chile acogiera los
potenciales diálogos no para un acuerdo
de paz con él ln bueno continuamos con
el país de españa que titula la
izquierda abre un camino inédito en
colombia y entre los desafíos que
atribuyen al presidente ya oficialmente
de cuero me ha gustado petro por ejemplo
alcanzar la paz total lograr múltiples
reformas económicas y sociales y en un
texto firmado por oquendo y lewin
señalan el 7 de agosto de 2022 es una
fecha que tendrá un significado por
décadas en la historia de colombia tras
dos siglos de vida independiente la
izquierda ocupa el poder con un ex
guerrillero gustavo petro como
presidente y una mujer afro nacida en la
pobreza a francia- márquez como obres
vicepresidenta también una
importantísima lideresa social y
destacan que el acto de posesión por
primera vez abrió al pueblo no dejó de
ser un acontecimiento reservado a la
élite política para abrirla precisamente
al pueblo colombiano que tanto ha
apoyado a la candidatura de petró y
márquez y precisamente ayer escuchábamos
no por ejemplo que la gente vitoreaba
petro amigo el pueblo está contigo y que
además que dice presidenta rosa
recordemos que se va a abrir un nuevo
ministerio de igualdad que va a presidir
la vicepresidenta francia marquesas y
que también va a ser ministra vamos
ahora con a pie en la prensa de colombia
el espectador y el país de cali
exactamente el espectador precisamente
no ante este apoyo y esta confianza
popular destaca la cita del discurso de
petro no podemos fallar y también
enumera alguna de las promesas como
trabajar por conseguir una paz verdadera
que quizás es la más importante porque
involucra no engloba muchísimas otras y
como bien de comentabas pues gobernar
con y para las mujeres luchar contra la
corrupción y proteger el medio ambiente
mientras el país de cali afirma el nuevo
presidente de los colombianos transmitió
un mensaje de esperanza en su posición
unas palabras que han tenido también
mucho eco hoy comienza la colombia de lo
posible y que dicen rosas los
editoriales del colombiano y el tiempo
pues el colombiano en este medio de
antioquia titula un buen arranque así
titula su editorial dice que la posición
estuvo llena de simbolismos no pues las
mariposas la guardia indígena la espada
de bolívar más allá también de lo que
simbolizan en sí como bien decíamos
petro y francia pero dice el colombiano
si nos dieran a elegir el retrato que
debe quedar para la historia es el de la
bienvenida de la cúpula militar y de la
policía ha gustado petro simboliza el
encuentro de dos mundos que por muchas
décadas décadas fueron contrarios y el
tiempo también titula el arranque de
petro y dice el diálogo los consensos y
el respeto a la constitución deben
fortalecerse ante los retos del país
rosa y ahora nos fijamos en los puntos
que la silla garcía destaca entonces del
primer discurso gustado petro como
presidente exactamente y en el que nos
hemos querido fijar es precisamente en
el punto que una referencia a la
política ambiental y de lucha contra el
cambio porque recordemos uno de los
principales eslóganes y promesas de
petro es que colombia sea como el dice
una potencia mundial de la vida bien en
todo caso la silla vacía' dice usar la
amazonía como carta de negociación
frente al cambio climático dice el
preside el presidente señaló que no
somos nosotros quienes emitimos los
gases de efecto invernadero son los
ricos del mundo que nos lo hacen pero
nosotros si tenemos la mayor esponja de
absorción de estos gases después de los
océanos la selva amazónica y que para
conservar precisamente el patrimonio
natural dentro de las fronteras
colombianas lanzó la propuesta siguiente
al fondo monetariointernacional cambiar
deuda externa por gastos internos para
salvar y recuperar las selvas bosques y
humedales colombianos muy rápidamente
rosas cerramos entonces con la historia
detrás de la comentada foto presidencial
exactamente porque una de las cosas que
suceden no ya cuando tras esta toma de
posesión es cambiar los retratos
presidenciales de las dependencias
públicas y ha sido muy comentada la
imagen oficial de gustavo petro ahí pues
quienes la han criticado a quienes
gustado lo que si hay un mes o incluso
hay mes e incluso exacto pues haciendo
montajes con la película de disney
encantó por ejemplo lo que sí que hay
que reconocer es que es original y sacan
al presidente del despacho presidencial
fue una imagen tomada por mauricio vélez
en caño cristales y el propio fotógrafo
cuenta al medio el tiempo que petro
quería algo distinto y salir de esta
imagen típica de guerra con la bandera y
precisamente mostrar una imagen de paz y
unidad y uso también este sitio natural
dice supremamente potente al que
llegaron tras un viaje en avión
helicóptero y 40 minutos a pie y hay
quien dice que se inspiró de la foto
oficial que se tomó también gabriel
boric eran adelante del mar de tunquén y
precisamente las fotógrafas responsables
responsables de la imagen del presidente
chileno palavecino y palomino destacan
que ese es el mar que todos vemos que
nos calma
gracias.rosa como siempre por esta
revista de prensa al día de hoy y mañana
con más por cierto vamos a sobre todo
claro que sí de esta toma de posición de
gustavo petro con nuestro segundo
invitado al día pero por ahora vamos a
saludar a nuestro primer invitado del
día de hoy